نقلت وكاله وطاس عنا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اسقطت 10
طائرات اوكرانيه مسيره فوق شبه جزيره
القرمه صباح اليوم اعترضت ثلاث مسيرات
اخرى باستخدام تدابير الكترونيه مضاده
هذا وقالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت 15 مسيره من نوع
شاهد خلال ساعه الماضيه واضافت الهيئه في
بياننا ان القوات الروسيه قصف الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بصاروخ مجنح ونفذت سبعة وخمسين
غار جويه كما اطلقت تسعه وعشرين مقذوفا من
راجمات الصواريخ خلال ساعه الاربعه
والعشرين الماضيه ما ادى الى مقتل واصابه
عدد من المدنيين والحاق اضرار بمنشات
للبنيه التحتيه واشارت الى ان الطائرات
الاوكرانيه نفذت احدى عشره غاره على مواقع
القوه الروسيه هيئه الاركان اكدت ان قوتها
صدتها هجمات روسيه في مقاطعه دونيتسكو
بينما هجومها في محوري مقاطعه
بدوره على ان الجيش الروسي انه استهدف
مواقع للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه في
اطراف خرسون ودمر وحدات مدفعيه كما اكد ان
قوته دمرت زوارق اوكرانيه في نهر دنيبر
واحبطت محاوله لنقل افراد من القوات
الاوكرانيه
دمرت وحدات المدفعيه التابعه لمجموعه
دنيبرو في منطقه
المدفعيه وانظمه صاروخيه مضاده للدبابات
على ساحل نهر دنيبر ودمرنا اربعه زوارق
فائقه السرعه وقتلنا ما يقارب 20 من
القوات الاوكرانيه اثناء محاوله نقلهم سرا
وتمكنت وحدات الاستخبارات من تحديد نظام
صواريخ سبادا المضاد للطائرات الايطالي
الصنع وتدميره باستخدام طائره مسيره من
طراز لانسيت